Traductor: Sean Mann
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En los desiertos del suroeste de EE.UU.
renacuajos del sapo pata de pala
salen de los huevos en pequeñitos oasis.
Hasta que se vuelvan sapos jóvenes
no pueden sobrevivir fuera del agua,
pero estos charcos son transitorios
y evaporan rápidamente.
Los renacuajos hacen
una carrera contra el tiempo
para crecer antes de que
desaparezcan sus criaderos.
Así que, casi de la noche a la mañana
algunas crías multiplican su tamaño.
Usan dientes de linterna de calabaza
e inmensos músculos de la mandíbula
para devorar a los compañeros
de charco más pequeños.
Nutridos por la comida extra,
se desarrollan más rápido, saliendo
del charco antes de que se seque.
El sapo pata de pala no es el único animal
que come miembros de su propia especie
como parte normal de su ciclo de vida.
Todos estos animales lo hacen.
Si eso les sorprende,
están en buena compañía.
Hasta hace poco, los científicos
pensaron que el canibalismo
era una escasa respuesta a
la inanición u otro estrés extremo.
Caníbales bien conocidos,
como la mantis religiosa
y la araña viuda negra,
se consideraban excepciones extrañas.
Pero ahora, sabemos que
más o menos representan la regla.
Aunque puede parecer contraproducente
que miembros de la misma especie
se comen entre sí,
el canibalismo puede promover
la supervivencia de la especie entera
reduciendo la competencia,
eliminando a los débiles,
y fortaleciendo a los fuertes.
Algunas especies,
como el sapo pata de pala,
canibalizan debido
a presiones medioambientales.
Su situación es precaria,
pero su canibalismo no es un intento
desesperado de evitar la inanición.
Más bien, es una manera de pasar
más rápidamente por una etapa
cuando son especialmente
vulnerables a la depredación
o a condiciones
medioambientales peligrosas.
Otras especies, incluso muchos peces,
se canibalizan indiscriminadamente
durante el forraje.
Los peces producen numerosas
crías pequeñitas,
y los adultos muestran casi el mismo
reconocimiento individual a sus crías
como los humanos por
un puñado de pasas.
Huevos, larvas y peces jóvenes son
comidas nutritivas y fáciles de conseguir,
y con miles de huevos en una puesta,
todavía hay muchos que eclosionan
después de que los adultos han merendado.
Los peces bebés no solo corren el riesgo
de ser canibalizados por adultos...
los hermanos se comen también.
Los huevos del tiburón toro
se desarrollan y eclosionan
dentro de los oviductos de la
madre en diferentes momentos
cuando las crías consumen
la yema de sus propios huevos,
comen los otros huevos y crías
hasta que un tiburón bebé
queda en cada oviducto.
Cuando salen, los tiburones jóvenes son
depredadores expertos y bien alimentados
que tienen mejores
oportunidades de sobrevivir.
Si bien no fueron consumidos
por falta de nutrientes,
los animales jóvenes son especialmente
vulnerables al canibalismo.
Hámsteres,
ratas,
y otras madres roedores
comerán a sus crías si están enfermos,
muertos,
o simplemente son demasiados
para alimentar.
En otros mamíferos,
incluso osos y leones,
los machos matarán a las crías
engendradas por otro.
Esto se debe a que las hembras sin hijos
son receptivas al apareamiento más rápido
que si cuidaran a un cachorro.
Antes que desperdiciar carne nutritiva,
los machos comen a los cachorros muertos.
Mientras tanto, el canibalismo es menos
común en las aves que en otros grupos,
pero ciertas especies comerán
crías enfermas o muertas
como manera de eliminar los cuerpos
antes que atraigan gusanos.
Cuando los adultos se comen, canibalizan
a los machos más que a las hembras
generalmente durante al apareamiento
y porque son más chiquitos.
Machos arañas espalda rojas australianos
aparean con hembras mucho más grandes.
En vez de huir después de aparear,
el macho chiquito hace una voltereta,
poniendo su vientre en contacto
con la boca de su pareja.
La hembra lo rocía con jugo gástrico
lleno de enzimas y consume su vientre.
Los machos no muertos por el apareo
inicial se arrastran hacia la batalla,
a menudo medio comidos,
a aparear de nuevo, después de lo cual
se les envían a la bodega de las arañas.
Así que el macho no solamente
provee su esperma a la hembra,
sino que también provee
una comida nutritiva
para mejor asegurar que
sobrevivirá a pasar sus genes.
Considerando todo, está claro
que el canibalismo
es tanto una parte de
la vida en el reino animal
como otras conductas mejores reconocidas.
Mientras hincamos el diente en la
evidencia del canibalismo en la naturaleza
nos podríamos preguntar:
¿Qué más hemos perdido al aplicar
los estándares humanos
al mundo de la naturaleza?